[拍手]
はぁ
ああああああ
写真館が西里申しますよろしくお願い致します
さて私は時々
こんなことを自問しています
皆さんの中には自分はもう
見つけているという方もいらっしゃるんですよ
中には今私は探している最中
そんな中のみらっしゃるかもしれません
私の場合は高校生の時
on 8位と世の中の役に立つ仕事をしたいというふうに思っていたんですけれども
実際何をやればいいかっていうのはものすごく悩んでいました
それを作ってくれたんだ30代の頃に出会ったら終わる工事原文です
これは共同溝というインフラを整備しているゲームはです
オフィス vine を歩いていくと工事現場が
a その中に入っていくといきなりこんな sfo の世界が広がっていました
自分のすぐそばに全く知らない空間ガードにも驚いたんですけれど
そこでいいインフラが整備されているということにもさらに驚きました
今日どうこうというのは地下にトンネルを掘ってそこにペンや
ます
水道などもライフラインを収めるための設備です
根源がに入ったことをえ私は
自分が
知ってるつもりになっていたんですけれども実は何も知らないんだということに気が
つきました
そこでそれ以外面白い現場があるんじゃないか
探してみました
ありました
これは宇宙の成り立ちを調べるための
研究室
これはひどもーほーじげん
これはゴミを燃やすあの償却雪
最初はこのようなものを大きいだけで撮影していたんですけれども
いつも家
このような暮らしを支えているゲームを撮影して発表することに意味があるんじゃない
か
思うようになって自分のやるべき事は少しずつ
明確になっていきました
これは福島第二原子力発電所も牛を撮影したものです
自分が使っている便器がどこから来ている
総理興味があって撮影させてもらいました
2005年の話です
この後大北があ
東日本 ic 妻を福島第一原子力発電所の事故です
事故が起きたときに撮影を通じて東京電力さんに知り合いになったかと言いました
その方に
方言は絶対に記録を残しとかなきゃいけないっていうことは伝えました
しかしその時点では自分が撮影するという気持ちは全然なかった
というのは
私は報道写真を撮っているわけではありませんでしたか
自分に適した誰か居るんだろうそんな風に思っていた
しかしいつまでたっぷのゲームあの人が撮ったよ
鮮明な写真とか
大からといって私そういうものしか白露されて来ませんでした
ですので
これじゃダメだと温度は自分が撮影する前提で比較所を東京店に2に提出しました
鮮明な写真分かり発表されてしまうと
そんな写真が撮れない各国の現場なんかとか
はい不安になってしまいます
30年も40でもあるような作業であれば
私たちもしれないだけで
作業を得る事ができませんので次世代の人に引き継いでもらう必要がある
ですから
不安暗所睡眠
ひろこを残す意味に
きちんと車撮影をする必要はあるそんな風に考えていたんです
実際に現場に入ったとか事故から3年も2014年のことです
この写真はその最初のヒント5000写真なんですけれども
大臣賞は意外と綺麗に片付いているというものでした
小直後の印象も沿っ強かっをその後情報がなかったことで
私の中のイメージも
超の直後から更新されていなかったんだと思う
私が風車の第二の撮影をしているというと
多くの方は放射線は大丈夫
そういう心配をしてください
しかし私は放射性に関してはあまり心配したことがないです
というのも
私が撮影にふと気にな原は憎らしい1あならずついていってくれます
またこの写真に写っているような
放射線を張る期待あなたが身に着けているんですね
私の撮影にはすべて言えることなんですけれども
すべての現場は
安全がきちんと管理されている現場なんですね
私がしてみると指の病の応対とは
aion 追いかけたりとかそういう撮影をしている写真家さんの横段ないようなとし
ていると思われてしまいます
放射線の心配はあまりしなかったんですけれども
私が心配していたのか
きちんとした写真が撮れるのかと
私も最初にゲームはに行った時はこのような皆さんと同じような
4期でいるんですけれどもこのまずをつけてしまいますと
阿部らの愛んなーっていうのは本当に一部者の付けなくなってしまいます
低袋はご綿の手袋を1枚した後に主に手袋今しなければいけ
そういうカメラこのように bl でツアーいなければいけなくなってしまいます
つるつる滑ってしまう
頭部にダイヤルなんかすごく回しづらい
自分はきちんとした写真を撮りに行こうに来たん
こんな状況で撮影ができる
それはもうすごく不安でした
ちょっと話が前後してしまいますけど
私は帰宅昇格何回かずっと悩んでいました
このゲームはをこのゲーム安定まな
やはり手を出してしまうもうがない大火傷してしまいその a 学んだからです
原子力発電に賛成の反対なん
何の目的でお前は撮影しているのか
そのようなことを知られるでしょうか
自分の頭などをきちんと整理する必要があったんですね
特に私が気になっていたのは主人の中立性についてです
この現場に関しては
不安をあおるようなないようなも多く見受けられます
ですから私はゲームはの良い所も悪い所
両方足らなければいけないと思って撮影に臨めまし
ただそれを全部スムーズいったわけではないんです
例えば後の写真えるめんとに汚染と書いてあります
この写真に対して東京電力参加
5000た文字を修正でげすか
それでも写真人なら削除してほしいという要望位
もうそんなことをしてしまったら広葉生の味自体がなくなってしまいますね
それは種子をきちんと説明して納得してもらいまし
これはに豊富場から35
見下ろして撮影した写真です
をの写真についてもいい顔されませんですよ
現場の片付いていないじゃんかよ
米もあってください
ゲームはの片付いていない状況今撮影したおかなければ
将来か付いた時の差がわからなくなってしまう
ですからそれをきちんと説明して納得していただきました
作業優れないところを取るんですけどもちろんなければすんねんっ
私が最初に入ったころはお昼わぁに出てくるのが3-1とジュースでした
それはだんだんお弁当になり2016年くらいから
このような食堂で当たらない食事が取れるようになりました
私は現場に行くと長女さんともうほとんど同じですから
この温かい食事がとれる本当にありがたかっ
俺ら2写真だけでは伝わりません
それは文書市でも伝えるように努力し
ああああああああ
中立性については
何が撮影したとしても結局その人の主犯があることは免れられませ
ですから厳密な中立というのはないんですね
私は自分がゲームはでみたいっ
感じたりした素直に伝えるようにしています
はをの上余が入ったことで私の基本的な撮影の方針です
例えばこのような写真を撮る時
ゲームはの方に撮影させてください猫絵は描けるんです
ですけどなあとはいつも取り作業してもらいます
最初は考えらを意識してしまって肌があってしまっているんですけれども
あー流れも上尾集中してきますから
総じてから撮影するようにしています
話題までは撮影したあといろんな箱ができますよね
でも私は em で自分が荒れてた e 賞以上の処理をしないようにしています
言えば理事論どんどんウソになってしまう
最近の要素はあまり報道されませんけれども
電話どんどん動いて言っています
この写真を汚染水の見えるパンティ側で撮影していますけれども
先ほどご覧いただいたような重装備はつけていません
ランタンのますとで風呂です
をないな現場に行った時は
もう江袋ません延命しなくてもあるからゲームようになっていました
今今後の二重装備をしなければいけないのはいえ城の周りなどごく一部になってきてい
ます
入るんだけど相撲て話し良き
もういままでやってきた作業っていう
汚染水の対策であったり
幻魔の放射線量を下げるための作業が中心でした
ですから音楽的な廃炉作業というのはまだ始まったばかりというのが現状だと思います
現実とイメージは違います
大切なのはその違うしようと努力する
です
言うまでもなく未来というのは私たち日々選択していること向こうあるん
でももし間違ったイメージをもとに選択を続けてしまうと
間違った未来ヒヨスでしまう
そういう危険性があります
皆様の中にかな
アレ泣くたのができない大もいなる方もいらっしゃると思います
空と思うんです
それはそれぞれ
たちは違い得意なものも違うからです
ですけれども重要なのはやるべきことを5件
それを実行することなんです
見えないというのは
与えられるものではないんです
自分たちので作らなければいけないんです
私にできることは
興味を持ってもらうきっかけを提供することだけです
4この試合が皆さんに a
次の行動をさんきっかけになることを願っています
ありがとうございました
[拍手]